okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about average speed so this is a short
lesson but still an important concept to
understand for the s80 and the form you
want to memorize if you don't know
already is the distance equals rate
times time formula so distance equal to
R times T and if you rearrange this
equation by dividing both sides by TV at
a time you can see that the rate is
equal to the distance divided by time
that's what the average speed is average
speed of the average rate as the
distance traveled divided by the time it
took okay so let's look at an example if
you can pause the video and do this one
on your own if a car travels 100
kilometers in a four-hour period what is
this average speed okay so pretty
straightforward right it's just saying
that the rate is equal to the distance
100 kilometers divided by four hours so
if you divide a hundred divided by four
you just get 25 km/h and that's it now
they might have you converted into a
different unit may be like meters per
second and so kind of like stacking you
know concepts on there let's unit
conversions and we talked about that in
another lesson but this one is just to
remind you of this formula which they do
test you on on that SI t is the distance
equals rate times time so i'll see you
in the next lesson